-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy Award-winning actor
you know from "The Birdcage,"
"Brockmire," and "The Simpsons."
He stars in "Hello Tomorrow!"
which is currently streaming
on Apple TV+ with new episodes
premiering Fridays.
Let's take a look.
-This is the moment my whole
life has been leading up to,
but this...
this is really it.
♪♪
-Jesus, Eddie.
-Because if it's a yes from you
about this,
I will never win
bigger than that.
Ever.
-Lot B-18.
-Midsize B-plex.
Full of charm.
Let's call it a beginning
of, uh...
of more than we can
currently know.
[ Chuckles ]
-It's great, Eddie.
You did great.
-Um, excuse me?
This is now. This...
Are we doing this or what?
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Hank Azaria.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, everybody.
-This is a fantastic new show.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-With a pretty trippy premise.
-Yeah.
-Can you lay it out for us?
-It's hard to lay out
the premise.
-It is -- I do think
it's a very difficult task.
-I've had practice for a year
and I'm still not great at it,
but it takes place in like
a Jetsons vision of the future.
Like the future we were promised
in the '50s but never got.
-Right, floating cars
and that sort of thing.
-Yeah, jet packs and robots
and things like that.
And these are con men, salesmen,
selling condos on the moon.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
You know, that old chestnut.
[ Laughter ]
Every year, they bring out
one of these.
And it was fun.
In the scene you saw,
you know, these guys...
He's really cynical,
he's a gambling addict,
and he would sell, you know,
his own mother anything.
And probably has.
-[ Laughs ]
-And yet he's caught up in
this dream of actually going...
They were talking about a condo
on the moon that they bought
and they're really psyched
to get up there and go.
-You mention
a gambling addiction.
This is...
-Yes.
-You've done this before.
You've played
a gambling addict before.
-I have played many addicts.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I've lived some of it, too.
-Yeah.
Well, "Brockmire,"
a show I loved --
you were an addicted gambler,
as well.
So this --
-Well, he was drug and...
He was addicted to everything.
-Yeah, he was.
-Sex, drugs, and rock and roll,
baby.
[ Laughter ]
He was, yeah.
-But, and you do --
you were a poker player.
-I still am.
I'm gonna play tonight.
-You are? You still play?
Good for you.
-I still play, yes.
-Because we faced off once.
-I remember.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
Celebrity poker.
-"Celebrity Poker Showdown."
-Yeah. This is years ago.
This is like
the early 2000 aughts.
-My buddies Andy Newman
and Josh Malina
actually produced that show.
-It was a really fun show.
-Well, you won, if I remember...
-I won the whole thing.
I should not have.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I was...
You know, at that time...
We played a no-limit
hold 'em tournament.
-Yep.
-And I was used to playing
stud poker, but, you know --
-A lot of excuses
right out of the gate here.
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
But you remember how bummed
I was when I lost?
-Yes. Well...
-I was, like, bereft.
I was really upset.
-There's a photo of both of us.
And it definitely...
If you just saw the photo,
you'd be like, "Oh, Hank
definitely is the one
who's gonna win this."
-Yeah.
-Look at the two --
I'm just falling to pieces.
[ Laughter ]
Look how confident you are!
-I was about to donkey off
all my stack
to Amy Poehler
right after that.
-Oh, that's right.
Poehler was in it, as well.
-Yeah, she took all my money.
-Well, I'm very sorry.
[ Laughter ]
This, by the way...
So, I've read
the show described,
which I think is a very accurate
description of the show --
"Mad Men" meets "The Jetsons."
-Kind of, yeah.
-A little "Glengarry Glen Ross"
in there as well, I feel.
-Definitely.
Con men salesmen.
-But it's this beautiful,
retro-y '50s look.
And these are, you know,
one of the robots there.
-Yeah.
-And it looks practical.
It does not look CGI.
But of course, there are...
You know, there is a method
to the madness.
-Well, yeah,
these robots were real,
meaning they were there with us.
They weren't added later.
But along with these robots
came these guys
in green unitards...
[ Laughter ]
...operating them as puppeteers.
And including like, yeah --
-That's a very good picture
of what you're talking about.
[ Laughter ]
-But, wait.
That actually was more sane
because they have their...
When they were operating
in the take,
they had green masks on, also.
-Right.
-So they were just, like, these
Mummenschanz green people.
[ Laughter ]
And you have to like...
I'm there trying to emote with
Emmy Award-winner Billy Crudup.
And there's these folks
all around you, like, going --
Nyeh, nyeh, nyeh!
[ Laughter ]
Nyeh!
And, but you get used to it.
-Yeah.
That, I guess,
is the weirdest thing,
the day where you realize
you're used to the green people.
[ Laughter ]
-It takes 10 minute-- well, all
of show business is like that.
-Right.
-It really is.
You know what was one of
the weirdest days of my life?
Like, being on the red carpet --
you know, the red carpet.
Whatever it was, the Emmys,
whatever it was.
And at first when
you're on that red carpet,
your, like, heart is pounding
in your throat.
You're like, "Oh, my God!"
You can't believe
you're in the middle
of this iconic, crazy thing.
And then you cut to
like 15 years later
and you're literally like,
[sighing] "Ah, man."
[ Laughter ]
"Gotta talk to 'ET', I guess.
Whatever.
Can we get it over with?"
-Yeah.
-Just feels like...
So, yeah.
Like, but, shooting
is nuts anyway
because before every take,
for example,
you know, makeup comes and
they're doing this to you,
and hair is doing this.
And like, it's like chimps
grooming each other.
[ Laughter ]
And they, like, pick stuff off
and actually eat it.
And people will...
You accept...
In right before
the moment you shoot,
you'll accept any behavior.
Like, they could spray-paint
your head.
-Yeah.
-Take off your clothes.
Like, "Oh, I guess
I'm naked in this take.
Whatever."
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, it's just like...
-The thing that always
shocked me about acting...
Obviously, I've done it far less
than you, but you do --
you think, as an actor,
all the notes are gonna be
about your performance.
-Yeah.
-And instead they go, "Cut!"
and the director's like,
"Move the curtain."
-Yeah.
-And you realize they're bare--
You're basically just one of
the other props in the shot.
[ Laughter ]
-Totally. Totally.
When you look at dailies,
when people watch and gather,
you know, the hair department
only sees hair.
-Yeah.
-The actors only look
at their performance.
Set Dec only sees
what's going on in the set.
And you know, I'll do a take
I thought was great,
and someone will go, "Ugh, God!"
I'm like, "What's --
What was wrong?"
Like, "Your hair was like that
in this one."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "Who cares?"
-Just get...
So, for in the future,
you should have a couple green
people just watching your hair.
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-I have a ton more questions.
We'll be right back with more
from Hank Azaria.